what's up guys and welcome to Haris
hobbies the channel where we discussed
the latest tech news and delve into the
newest tech products today we're taking
a look at why the gtx 1180 is basically
just a Titan xp for just $700 but Before
we jump into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and the PCs so
what happened and why is there so much
hype about the insane performance of the
next generation GPU well recently there
was a crazy leak that revealed insane
specs for the gtx 1180 now before we
continue these are just leaks and there
are rumors as well so just make sure to
keep that in mind so what exactly is so
great about the gtx 1180 and what is
this rumor suggesting well first of all
the new of gtx 1180 is going to go on to
the 12 nanometer process instead of the
16 nanometer process that we have right
now however the die size is actually
increasing from 314 millimeters squared
on the gtx 1082 400 millimeters squared
on this new gtx 1180 but this die size
increase is more than justified for
example this new GPU is supposed to have
3584 cuda cores performance now to put
that in perspective that GT x 1080 had
2560 and the titan XP has 3840 so as you
guys can see this new gtx 1180 is really
close to Titan XP in terms of CUDA cores
but that's not where the similarities
ended the GT X 1080 has 8.7 teraflops of
performance and the Titan XP has called
teraflops of performance however this
new gtx 1180 is supposed to have 13
teraflops of performance so as we can
see the gtx lemonade is actually pulling
ahead of the Titan XP in this area
memory speed is also going up the GTX
had ten gigabit per second memory the
Titan XP has 11.4 gave it per second
memory while the new gtx 1180 is
supposed to have 16 bit per second
memory however what's odd is that the
memory bandwidth is actually taking a
hit for the gtx 1180
so the gtx 1080 has a memory bandwidth
of 320 gigabytes per second while the
Titan XP has five hundred and forty
seven points seven gigabytes per second
the new gtx 1180
is supposed to have 512 gigabytes per
second so it's nothing laughs at but
it's not as high as the titan XP but
still really good on top of this the gtx
1180 is supposed to have GD d r 6 memory
which is supposed to be exponentially
better than the gddr5 x memory that the
gtx 1080 and titan XP currently use as a
result we should be seeing a huge
performance upgrade in that area as well
the final icing on the cake is that this
new gtx 1180 is only supposed to consume
170 to 200 watts as opposed to the 250
watt TDP of the titan XP overall as you
guys can see from these specs the gtx
LED mini looks very promising and should
at least match if not exceed the
performance of the titan XP so next up
how much is this going to cost well if
you guys have been following me for a
while you would know that I told you
guys that this is probably going to be
more expensive than what the GTX 1080
came out for because of the inflated Ram
price and the current cryptocurrency
mining situation that we have
however this leak is actually suggesting
that the gtx 1180 is going to be coming
out at an MSRP of $700 which is the same
MSRP that the gtx 1080 released for so
as you guys can see that's really good
value if this actually comes true the
MSRP of the Titan XP is $1200 and if you
want to pick one up right now it would
easily cost you over $1500 due to the
horrible GPU situation right now so if
this all works out and your
actually getting in tight neck speak for
less than half the price that you would
be able to get it right now so this is
really great news so this all looks
really promising and all but what
exactly is this new GPU supposed to come
out well we were expecting that Nvidia
may say something at GDC but
unfortunately they didn't even drop any
hints
however at GDC gamer Nexus was actually
able to discover that SK Hynix was
planning their mass production of GDB r6
memory in just three months so if you
guys didn't know SK Hynix is the memory
producer for Nvidia graphics cards so as
a result if they are starting mass
production of gddr3 that probably
indicates that the next series of GPUs
is coming very soon so gamers Nexus
found this information at the end of
March so according to what SK Hynix is
suggesting they should probably start
their mass production of gddr3 at the
end of June or at the beginning of July
so as a result we could probably expect
these new GPUs like the GTX 1180 and
1170 near the end of July or the
beginning of August this is actually
what article on Tom's Harbor suggested a
few months ago and this new leak also
suggests that so most likely the next
series of GPUs are probably coming out
mid to late summer and then lower tier
cards like the 1160 and maybe 1150 or
come out later this year and some other
variants like the 1150 Ti and lemon atti
will probably come out next year so what
does this exactly mean in real-world
performance though so if we assume that
the gtx 1180 is really similar to the
titan XP then we would know that this
new GPU would be able to handle most if
not all current games at 4k at at least
60 frames per second it should probably
actually be able to handle at 70 or
above but at least 60 for all games at
max settings on top of this this
graphics card should crush triple
monitor 1080p gaming and also q HD ultra
gave me so if you guys are interested in
any of those types of gaming styles then
this may be a great GPU for you guys
overall even in the real world this GPU
should provide insane performance so
it's definitely worth waiting for if you
guys have the money to buy it so who all
should exactly wait for this new GPU
well first of all you need to have the
money to buy it so if you have the mind
to buy it should you wait or not in my
opinion you should definitely wait if
you don't really need upgrade right now
if you're like a new upgrade would be
nice right now like going to 1080i or
1080p no really need it then I
definitely recommend that you guys just
stick it out and wait for the 1180
because it's just so much better
also GPU prices are really inflated
right on anyways they are coming down
but they're still above MSRP so it
doesn't really make that much sense to
buy a GPU right now anyways but that's
for the enthusiast users so what about
the mid-level users like the 1060 and
1070 and 1050 well if you guys are
considering any of those cards and don't
need an upgrade then I still recommend
that you guys wait for it I know for
some of those cards like the eleven
sixty and LAN fifty it may be quite a
wait until the end of this year but it
definitely will be worth the way I think
so we don't really know how those are
going to perform but if we assume that
Nvidia gives us past generational gaps
then it should be great India definitely
has the technology to provide us with
that so it would make sense for example
last generation the 1060 and the 980
were quite comparable as a result this
generation we may see that the eleven
sixty and 1080 are comparable and on top
of that the 1168 should implement G DDR
6 memory and should hopefully be offered
for a much better price than what the
1060 is being offered for right now so I
really recommend that all of you guys
consider waiting if you can now if
you're like some more performance would
be great
but I don't really care about it and I
would be satisfied with what I can get
right now then of course you just go
ahead and buy it but just make sure to
consider the option of waiting before
you make any rash
so what do you guys think about the gtx
1180 you thing as overkill and you're
not gonna buy it or are you like can
this one shall I make sure to post down
in the comments below what you guys
think about this I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like it
really does help and make sure subscribe
to this channel if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this one
but until next time
[Music]